significant
all right excellent thank you all for
for coming back uh uh we will continue
on today's theme of classification and
we will use what we built today uh what
we described previously about grass
falsification to build fast LaPlace and
solvers and as I was saying in the
morning uh I I think it would have been
a shame if you had not even seen what is
a fossil Plus in solver
I want to tell you what is
I will definitely be able to show you
how to build one
uh not the best one but a reasonably
good one and hopefully basically show
you all the elements of the proof right
it's somewhat ambitious uh but but I'll
try to stick with it I'm still happy to
take questions but uh a request to keep
the questions focused on the material
I'm happy to take the generalizations uh
after right they can go to lunch and
talk about those
super
so let me remind you why we might want
to solve the placings right
yesterday when we were talking about uh
electric linear systems we said you can
compute the voltages given your current
demands net currents are the vertices
exactly by Computing L inverse t
this is what we call solving a LaPlace
in linear system so I give you a vector
d
you want to give me
V which is L University
and as a simple application of course
you need to this in order to be able to
solve electrical systems
right simple resistive system but it
turns out this primitive is really
really useful
here are an insane number of
applications of fast LaPlace and solvers
it started all the way back in
scientific Computing finite element
methods and then you can plug these into
interior Point methods I should also
cite digital Spillman here I'm sorry
that's not that's not here you can use
it for learning on graphs lots of fast
faster flow algorithms drop partitioning
sampling random spanning trees graph
specification
all of these need fast algorithms for
solving LaPlace in linear system
and the first almost linear time linear
solver for LaPlace in linear systems is
due to Spelman and Tang and for the
amount of influence this work has had on
the design of us algorithms they were
awarded with a good L price for this
result in 2015.
uh shout out to baija for uh thank you
so thanks for so there was a time when I
was thinking I would do you know like a
history slide of this entire field I
have not had time but really before
before experimenting happened the idea
of of using graph structure in order to
speed up linear algebraic questions is
really due to why they are uh he he used
he he built
Plus in linear systems than solving
matrices right for graphs not the best
not almost any time but really he
introduced the key ideas of using trees
in order to speed them up uh and uh
really like sort of INSP like it's like
Dan always fire sites were there as a as
a big inspiration in all of us
so definitely uh where there is a key
player into how
how actually this program came about
really so because one Spillman and tank
happened this original paper was huge
over 100 pages and had a lot of ideas
that has given rise to many like those
ideas have trickled down into many many
works and are basically used almost
without citation today in in the space
of fast algorithms but grass
classifications field one show us that I
showed you uh originated here in a much
more complicated way a local graph
partitioning originated here uh in in a
in a tricky way which became a subfield
of its own right and today I will show
you a linear system solver that actually
does not use
any of the tools they built
directly but I mean all the ideas have
sort of been distilled over the two
decades of works that has followed since
so I hope to show you a much simpler
much simpler proof of solving LaPlace in
realness systems
okay and again any questions please feel
free to stop me
super so before I tell you
about the algorithm I need to tell you
that we will not solve these systems
exactly
right so if I wanted to solve LX equals
to D exactly the answers can be very
long they can require n digits
in order to just write down the answer
so we will not write them exactly but
we'll write them
approximately but with very high
precision
and what do I mean we will return a
vector X tilde
which is a Delta approximate solution in
the following sense
it's nor the norm of the error Vector X
tilde minus L inverse d
is Delta smaller than the norm of the or
this is a like the true solution x l
inverse d
right so relative to the scale of the
two solution the error is Tiny you
should think of Delta as 1 over poly n 1
over n to the 100.
right so it doesn't have to be constant
it can be really tiny so which means I
can write down login with
of answer in every coordinate basically
it's interesting to use the norm uh like
you for convenience if you would like
you can think of this as the L2 Norm but
when doing the proofs it turns out to be
more convenient to work with what is
called the norm given by the laplacian
which is just the square root of the
quadratic form of the laplacian
right it's uh it's an easy exercise to
verify that this is a a semi Norm right
a semi Norm because it actually has a
kernel but that will not matter for most
of our applications
right so
under the error measured by the by the
laplacian we will give a Delta
approximate solution with Delta is Tiny
polynomial is small inverse
polynomialism
the notion of what it means to
approximately solve a system here
right so nowhere are we going to compute
the inverse of The Matrix
right this is key this is even though
when we are usually taught what it means
to invert a system you say oh compute
the inverse of the Matrix multiplied
with the vector nobody ever
computationally does that nobody like if
you're doing that you're doing something
really wrong
you can much more fast you have much
faster algorithms to compute this
product
uh right which is finally a vector that
you want to Output
and this is called solving a linear
system
right it turns out that this laplacian
Norm is actually the right Norm you want
to solve it in for many applications but
we'll probably not be able to see that
today
so spiritual in time originally gave an
algorithm that had a large unspecified
number of logs which was estimated
around 70. over over the almost two
decades since there have been a sequence
of work with by many people also in the
audience here and finally
um Arun and Aaron in 2021 actually
achieved an algorithm with a running
time of M poly log log
there's not even a log n term so in some
ways this is really faster than sorting
I mean I'm cheating because you you're
working with numbers that already that
have login bits but in some way but the
number of operations is faster than the
number of operations you would need to
use sort the edge weights
use comparison
but a wrong audience to to make that
analogy but you're right mikhil but it's
better than the N log inbound for
sorting
okay I'm going to try to present to you
an algorithm that I think is very simple
to describe and also fairly simple to
prove especially once you know graph
falsification means from a recent paper
with my student it appeared at spa this
year uh it will not be the best
algorithm we'll achieve M log to the
foreign time but which is usually good
for most purposes right like yes you pay
extra poly log but what you don't want
to pay is M squared
right so it's almost linear time but
hopefully the algorithm will be easy to
describe and I'll give you the elements
of the proof
right and if you're wondering why did it
appear at spa it's because it's also a
parallel algorithm with log squared and
depth
okay so before I
I start showing you the pieces let let's
just talk about solving a few simple
systems of linear equations
one of the simplest ones to solve or
what are called well conditioned systems
what do I mean by well conditioned you
should let's say I want to solve ax
equals B any PST Matrix that is
approximately the identity
right in the same spectral notion of
approximation so all your eigen values
are let's say between 1.5 and 0.5 I mean
that's not what this but but roughly
between a small constant and a large
constant
you can do something very simple you can
do the following iterative operations
I start with any initial value x 0 and
at every step I update x minus What's
called the residual ax minus B
right you take the difference and you
subtract it from the current estimate
and you just keep iterating it's a fixed
Point operation on this equation right I
want the difference to be zero but if
there's some difference I'll subtract it
from the identity and keep repeating
you can easily show that this converges
how let me give you a one line proof
look at the difference from the optimal
solution
x i plus 1 minus X star
goes from the previous difference gets
multiplied by identity minus a
identity minus a is a matrix that has
eigen values strictly between plus 0.5
minus 0.5
or let's say 0.9 and minus 0.9 for
convenience so as you iterate this
process like let me bound this in the
norm you get the spectral Norm of
identity minus a as you entered this
process this error will Decay
geometrically for 9 to the minus t
and you get a guarantee in the same
notion of approximation that my solution
is close to the optimal solution
in the norm measured by The Matrix
after log 1 over Delta iterations if I
want to achieve Delta
and this is key for achieving inverse
polynomial error right if I had a 1 over
Delta iterations that's very slow
because I have to pay a large factor in
order
and log one over Delta is great I just
paying a login Factor 10 log n i can
achieve
1 over n to the 10 you know
is this algorithm an idea clear
okay
get along again
you're going to use the difference
uh I don't know if anything that gets to
a normal line right because Newton's
method Newton's method for one already
requires inverting a matrix
so it sort of defeats the
set because these operations are not
inverting any Matrix and this is
much cheaper so you have to do log one
or Delta multiplication of The Matrix
which is usually very quick especially
if the Matrix is parse so the word
that's right those log laws are coming
from a lot of graph uh graph
partitioning
but before I say more Alan is in the
audience and Aaron is in the audience
and I and you can ask them all questions
these are a very interesting graph
partitioning claims that
a job
that's where they pop up
right so this is a very simple algorithm
that solves anything that is a small
constant approximation to the identity
you can generalize this a little bit
into what is called iterative refinement
which is as follows if I want to solve a
system ax equals B
I can make it simpler by coming up with
a c that satisfies two properties one it
approximates my original Matrix
and two it's easy to invert
I'm not saying there always exists one
but if you could come up with one
that approximates my Matrix
and
is easy to invert then I would solve a
different linear system where I multiply
both the sides by C inverse
and now C inverse is cheap to compute
and this system has eigenvalues that are
close to one
so you can do the same algorithm but now
with C inverse a and just writing the
explicit iteration and show that it
converges to a Delta approximate
solution in log one
right
so this will be our goal our goal is
going to be that for solving a laplacian
linear system if you want to come up
with
another system that's easier to invert
much easier
and approximate my original laplacian
now maybe that thinks you why we will
come up with graph specification
right is the objective clear come up
with a matrix C
that approximates the laplacian
and is easy to invert
and to do that we are going to Tool use
a tool from an algebra called
blockchainless key factorization
okay what is block velocity
factorization not all of us have seen it
or maybe if you've seen it we don't
remember it so let's recall it
completely so here's my Matrix laplacian
I'm going to break it up into like y
break up the vertices break up the
vertices into two sets F and T
and that splits The Matrix into four
components a b b transpose C right b b
transpose because it's a symmetric
Matrix
like f and T form or partition of my
vertices
given any such partition block to
elastic factorization allows you to
write a factorization
of our Matrix has a product of three
matrices
okay let's read out the factors in just
a second but let me first identify you
have a lower triangular Matrix on the
left
right there's a 0 in the top right here
it's block lower triangular I should
identify right like uh I mean well
because you have identity youth it's
actually completely lower triangular but
it could have been block lower
triangular in general
upper triangle on the right and same as
transpose of this one so you get it's
usually also called an LDL transpose
ldlt this is you might see the
saccharine somewhere ldlt
lower triangular
block diagonal matrix
transpose of the lower triangular
and I will not like it's a you it's easy
to sort of multiply these three things
and verify that you actually get the
same Matrix
the focus here is the block is the block
diagonal one the top left block diagonal
is the same
a
the lower block diagonal term changes
significantly it's called the sure
complement the sure complement turns out
to be C which was your original
Matrix in the bottom right
minus B transpose a inverse B
I will keep reminding you of this
whenever I use it
this it's difficult to see how like I
don't have a great way how would you
come up with this from scratch but if I
show you this it's a very easy
multiplication to verify that you get
back
this is a very very nice factorization
why because now
uh you get two nice things
one you get and when you start with the
laplacian
the sure complement is also a laplacian
the proof is not not difficult let me
tell you how but I will leave it as an
exercise all you have to verify is that
the row sums are zero
and the off diagonals
a negative and the diagonals are
positive
right it's these are you can you can
sort of show all of these three facts
you end up with showing those issue
complement is also
so so that's the first thing the sure
complement gives me a factorization
where
then where the block diagonal has
laplacian yes
good sorry thank you sorry I I'm I'm a
little too used to this notation so
please uh so it's a sure compliment let
me read this more carefully so
I will I will end up using some notation
let me explain this process can be
considered as eliminating the variables
F right turns out that this is exactly
what you are doing under the hood when
you are doing gaussian elimination I
will not show that connection but doing
gaussian elimination is exactly this
when you eliminate the variables f
and the sure complement is like you have
to specify the Matrix and you have to
specify
what are the vertices on which you are
taking a short complement so I'll read
this as I'm taking the sure complement
of n
on to the mid on to the vertices given
by T
sometimes people use a notation of
eliminating like specifying which
vertices you eliminate but I think it's
cleaner to think of what vertices I'm
projecting the The Matrix onto
right and so that that will shrink the
vertices and project in the middle
does that clarify so it's a sure
complement of my laplacian onto t
and you get C is the T by T sub Matrix
original one and you get T by f
by f f by T
right so it's a so it's a t by T Matrix
characterization of Matrix classes that
are closed undershirt complementing
excellent question the question is is
there a nice characterization of Matrix
classes that are closed initial
complement I can give you an entire book
about it but there's no there's there
are a few rules that you do these
operations and it's closed additional
complement but it's not complete
and I couldn't find anything interesting
that we could try to generalize LaPlace
good uh question is is there a graph
theoretic interpretation of this yes the
interpretation is in terms of I will
show you a second one but the but the
but the first interpretation you should
think of is that this is doing gaussian
elimination in your laplacian linear
system right if I take a variable I want
to eliminate it so what happens is you
you you delete the vertex and the
neighboring edges and now you put a
weighted click on its neighbors
right but I will actually show you a
nicer interpretation in just a bit
fertilization interest I focused on the
Block diagonal but what about these
these are very nice systems right they
are triangular they have identities on
the
triangular on the Block diagonal things
these matrices are very very easy to
invert in fact I can just explicitly
write the inverse of the laplacian as
now an upper triangular Matrix
here all I've done is take taken the
transpose and put a minus sign that's
exactly the inverse of my
of my lower triangular Matrix so you get
an upper triangular Matrix the inverse
of the block diagonals so a inverse
should complement inverse
and then
the lower triangular Matrix
this is just the transpose of my
right so I have it's a way to express
the complete factorization
yes and and the key point will be that
we will pick
a that is easy to invert very easy
okay if a is easy to invert then these
parts are all easy
and the question becomes can you invert
the short complement but now the short
complement is just a smaller graph so
you can hope to recurse
it's a pseudo inverse but think of it as
L inverse
so far because L has an as a
and as a kernel so you cannot invert it
explicitly but just think of the
alieners like all of the formulas I'm
writing are explicitly true with L
inverse with inverse of matrices if you
just completely ignore the all One
Direction
right so does this does this broad
approach help right like I will need two
things
uh a that is easy to invert
and how do I recurse on the social
complex these are the two things I need
to specify
right so if you do unfold the recursion
what happens is that here's what I'm
going to do I'm going to approximate the
shortcut I'm not going to build out the
should complement turns out the shoe
complement is very dense
the exact will come I'm going to
approximate it implicitly without
actually building it explicitly
so that gives me that I get a graph
approximation to
to the sure complement
and then I will recurse on this
laplacian
in the end you end up building
an approximation to your original
laplacian
as a product
of
lower triangular matrices
block diagonal and a product of upper
triangular matrices
right not many these will like we will
this will just the depth will be log n
so you have log n
log n lower triangular block diagonal
log n upper triangular matrices
and these up and these triangular
matrices are easy to invert
it will be in inverting
it's a long time in United States
and I said approximate why is
approximate Enough by iterative
refinement
right iterative refinement we said all
you need is something that's easy to
invert and a good approximation and
we'll we will achieve an Epsilon
approximation here
yes questions
I didn't understand how do you get this
D many because I I recurse on the should
complement to do a triangle of
factorization it needs just a little bit
of uh verifying to work that if I have a
factorization in here of the sub Matrix
you can basically write it as
again like full upper triangular
matrices outside
right that just needs verification
because these are all identity and that
really helps with the way it works
right
good question so question is do I use
the fact that it's a plastic I will use
it at exactly one place how do you build
an implicit spots how do you build a
sparsal fire of the sure complement
implicitly that will heavily use the
fact that there's a graph interpretation
and and this is another plastic
otherwise this is a very general recipe
uh and works for many materials uh the
other place I'll use it is that finding
a sub Matrix that's easy to import
and if we're given a general PSD Matrix
I don't know how to find a large sub
Matrix that's easy to import now
another question
we'll basically to reduce remove
constant fraction of vertices every time
so D is going to be log n
okay good so so let's see so I already
mentioned this that we'll use it at a
refinement so now we need to specify two
things
how do you find AI that are easy to
invert
and two how do you build an
approximation a sparse approximation to
the sure complement
efficiently and without actually
building out the shoot complement right
I don't even have time to write out the
social compliment it's too dense right
it could have all all non like all the
entries could be non-zero so I can't
write it out so I need to build a sparse
approximation without writing it up
was going to be cc is going to be
happening yeah I'll end up with Epsilon
so you also need to estimate the
accumulated error over that's right
that's it but because of the so I need
to estimate the error but because of the
multiplicative property of this error
right I uh like when when taking
successive approximation the errors just
add up
so at every step I will have error
Epsilon my login and I will do that
login times to end up with total error
Epsilon
and you're going to end
my goal is to end up with an
approximation here that's a small
constant and I can use it
more questions
okay super so let's answer the first
question that turns out to be pretty
easy
you can find large sub matrices of the
laplacian that are easy to invert
and let me show you how I'm going to
find me some matrices that are strongly
diagonally dominant let me Define this
so I will say a matrix is 5 diagonally
dominant like there's there is a
definition called diagonally dominant
let me not like which will be equivalent
to one diagonal dominant but I'll just
Define five diagonal dominant
if
your diagonal term
is larger than 5 times the sum of the
off diagonal terms
right so really it's diagonal heavy
your diagonal is a constant Factor
larger than some of the off diagonal
it's actually pretty easy to show
that for a five DD Matrix if like okay
maybe this for a five diagonally
dominant Matrix its diagonal is actually
a constant approximation to The Matrix
itself
right this is It's a pretty easy proof
all you have to observe is that
a one diagonally dominant Matrix is
actually PSD
right so I can write my five diagonal
dominant as a large diagonal plus a PST
Matrix that's smaller strictly smaller
by a factor four like you lose another
Factor two and you get
a half approximation
to PSD Matrix is here I all yeah good
all of my talk columnistically stink
but in particular 5dd implies that you
are a PC strictly positive definitive if
your diagonals are not
right so but this is great because my
diagonal is easily invertible
so I can use it to do refinement again
so this means that if I can find a large
5D Matrix I can invert it quickly
right and that will be an answer to what
our mind is
so what I need to show you is that so
like they can be solved using iterative
and I need to sorry I should not be
seeing all of this together I need to
show you that you can find quickly
large Sub sub matrices
of the laplacian that are five
diagonally dominant
let me just add an animation here
slowly
okay how do you find these five diagonal
terms right this is just a definition
our diagonal has to be five times larger
than the sum of the off type
okay
first observation laplacian is one
diagonally dominant
right the diagonal is the sum of the off
diagonals
so this sort of means that if I was to
pick a random subset
small
I expect to see far fewer of diagonals
and that will basically be my algorithm
so here's what I'll do right it's a it's
a Lemma from a paper from Lee
Pennsylvania
uh I will first start by picking each
vertex to be in the set independently
with a small probability let's say 1 by
20.
so it's a large set right with high
probability
let me even say it's like exactly n by
20. so so it's a large subset
Now by Marco
if I look at a vertex in a
what is the expected sum of like not
even Marco what is the expected sum of
its off diagonals
diagonals is exactly equal to the
diagonal over 20 because each of the
other terms is included in the sum
independently with probability 1 over
20.
right so I expect to only see one
twentieth of my diagonal
so by Marco
I what is the probability that I satisfy
the five DD condition
it satisfies it with three-fourth only
fails with one-fourth right because it
was 1 over 20
4 times the expectation is diagonal over
five
so by applying simple Marco I I should
only fail with probability one over
fourth
right so now how many vertices in a do I
expect to see failing
one fourth of the set
so again with probability half at most
half of it fails
right and I apply a second Markov and I
get
140 n over 40 size subset
that's 5 DD
yes just for visualization so this is
like the opposite of a sports academy
right so you're saying every that's
right every vertex that's right it's
fantastic you should think of idd set as
a as a generalization not as a weakening
of independent sense an independent set
would be infinite DD because in that sub
Matrix you will only have off
icularly are diagonal terms
right it's a generalization I can afford
some of diagonals but they should not
add up comparable to that so you have
most of your Edge weights going out of
this
thank you
that's a very good way
right so pick a random set of size n
over 20 and then throw out the ones that
violate your condition you will end up
with high probability with a set or
maybe with constant probability with a
set of size and over 40 that's at that
is 5 DD
and the good thing is throwing out
vertices only improves the 5D condition
for the vertices that you keep right
otherwise I would have a conflict so it
since it only improves everything that
satisfies previously will continue to
satisfy
super so I've specified how to find
these large idd matrices you can invert
them quickly because diagonal is a good
preconditional
right so that's that checks one key
requirement we want
so the only thing missing is that how do
you build sparse approximations to the
sure complement implicitly
okay this uh might feel a little more
math either slides but I want to say
there's good interpretations please stop
me
if the ideas are not clear but let me
pause here to make sure all of us
you can recap our process if you want to
we are building
iteratively we are building these
approximations right we use blockchain
factorization you've got lower
triangular block diagonal upper
triangular
the the vertices we chose to eliminate
is a 5D set
right so that means that sub Matrix is
really quick to invert like the a top
left sub Matrix in a block to risky
factorization is really quick to invert
with the help of iterative refinement
and the only piece remaining is how do I
build a sparse approximation and then I
can recurse on the sure complement
right and since I'm finding constant
fraction at every step I'll have log n
iterations of recursion so that is also
worked out the only piece missing is how
do I build a good approximation to the
sure complement implicitly
okay so let's try to see if we can
complete that part
so before we do that
is the obstacle which the block Chelsea
factorization the key problem is that
you get what is called fill in this is a
line
the language used in the numerical
linear algebra Community whenever you do
gaussian elimination if you decide to
eliminate one variable
and it had edges related to four of
these
when you do the elimination what you end
up with is a click on all your neighbors
and suddenly the number of non-zeros in
the remaining Matrix has gone up
right you started with four now I have
six but it's a quadratic case so if you
eliminate a high degree vertex you
suddenly get a very dense graph
so we can't even afford to build
the sure complement explicitly
we are going to use the graph theoretic
interpretation to build these
approximations
to do that to do the approximation let
me first tell you what is the exact
interpretation of sure complements in
terms of
graphs and random works
okay
let's take this slowly it's going to
have some math but the interpretation is
actually very neat so I'm just recalling
what is uh complement we broke up or
like a we took a partition of the
vertices that broke up our matrices into
four pieces
and the sure complement is C minus V
transpose a inverse B
B transpose correspond to cut edges
between F and T
a is the Matrix restricted
to my five DD set right
and remember this Phi DD set has most of
its Edge weights going outside there are
some staying within without so at every
step like if you were taking a random
work inside a
you will exit it with probability four
fifth at every iteration
so let's let's now interpret the sure
complement in terms of random Works to
do that I will write
my a matrix as the diagonal weighted
degree
minus h
so D is the weighted degree in the
original graph not in the vertex
distributed subgraph it's in the
original graph
and H are my edges that stay Within
within the set f
is is
sorry this is f by F okay I'm writing a
as 2 F by F matrices
so it's a smaller matrices thank you
okay
I am claiming
this a inverse right
a inverse which is D minus h
right
D is a heavy diagonal very heavy right
five DD
H is the use of diagonal terms
it turns out that like the same property
we are using for iterative refinement
also says well all the eigenvalues of H
are much smaller when when viewed
relative to D so they're like small
constants plus minus 0.5
that means
you can actually apply the power series
to invert a
right all of you have seen the Formula 1
by 1 minus X is 1 plus X Plus x square
all right up to Infinity for this holds
for X small
you can apply that to matrices when all
your eigen values are small
so the inverse of identity minus a
for when eigen values of a are small is
exactly identity plus a plus a square
all the way up to infinity and this is
exactly what was being used in iterative
refinement in some sense right you can
you view the iterative refinement as
picking the first K terms of the power
series ignoring the rest and you get
error that's comparable to a to the k
so let me apply that power series
expansion to this
inverse here
right it it needs some more manipulation
because it's not identity but you can
factor out identity one way or the other
and you get an explicit equality the
sure complement is exactly equal to C
which is your original
Matrix entries in the T by T entry minus
B transpose from here
here's an expansion for a inverse a
inverse looks like it's worth reading
out the first few entries the first
entry is D inverse
the second entry is D inverse h d
inverse
the third entry is D inverse h d inverse
h d inverse
and so on all the way to Infinity so you
write this infinite
expansion for a inverse and you have a B
on the right
we pause here to make sure all of us
at least believe
this
this and how and are able to interpret
what this says I'll interpret it in
terms of graphs but I hope you see the
matrices yes is it
you need to have a strong 5 DB property
to kind of interpret your complement
good so so the question is do I need the
5D property to interact inverse uh so
for laplacians it's okay you need one DD
basically you want the diagonal my you
want all the eigenvalues of H to be
small relative to the eigen values of D
strictly less than one basically the
power C is expansion only holds if x is
strictly less than plus minus like
within the interval plus minus one right
so the eigen values of H related to D
should be strictly between plus minus
one
which is okay for laplacian but not okay
for General matrices General PSC
matrices
yeah you need connectivity thank you
I am assuming thank you guys yeah sorry
I did not mention this throughout
everything I'm doing I'm assuming that
the graph is connected by edges of
non-negative weight uh That's essential
because but also it's easy to assume
because if it's not you can invert the
laplacian's independently
yes question mentioned that this kind of
expansion holds for last year yes do we
assume that all the eigen values are
small they are not small but they are
small relative to the added
this is put for the entire LaPlace you
know yeah if this as long as this was
one DD not your idd then you would get
an expansion but you need and you need
sort of strictly one DD none of them
should have any questions
okay
formula you can actually now interpret
in terms of random works on the graph
before I write down what it is let's
let's just observe what's happening see
on the edges already exist
B are the edges that are going from like
between F to T
so so think of it as follow as as the
following
I
I walk from T to f
okay
then D inverse which means I distribute
my probability distribution according to
the degrees
and then take an edge
inside f
I work from T to F take a random step
like I keep walking inside F until you
exit with an edge that comes back to T
okay I'll State this formally just like
just for completeness but you walk from
t
to F and you walk inside F until you
exit with an edge
back to T
and this is exactly formal so here's a
recipe to build the shoe complement
exactly
I will take all walks
right like a path you can repeat
vertices you can repeat edges everything
I'll take all walks that start at a
Vertex x and t
walk
only through vertices in F
right like it's uh
all the internal vertices are strictly
enough
and then you're allowed to end at the
vertex back in t
take all of these walks
and you assign them some particular
weight I'll tell you the weight in just
a second but you assign them a fixed
particular weight add an X Y Edge
with that weight this is exactly the
sure complement
and it's just by interpreting these
terms here
right and what is the weight that you
put on it the weight you put on it is
is of ratio the numerator is the product
of Weights of all the edges
if I have if I if I take x u v y I have
three edges take the product of all the
three edges up here
in the denominator you want the degrees
of only the vertices in F
so you the internal two internal what it
is if my if I walk was length like if my
walk was x u v y
right so there are total four vertices
three edges the numerator has a product
of Three Edge widths the denominator has
the product of degrees of only the two
internal vertices
and that's really popping out of here
you
okay all of this is completely
coming out of this formula is there a
summation
good so I'm saying for all work you add
this so you'll get parallel edges X to Y
with different weights
it's it's not a unique way of specifying
an XYZ you add all possible search X Y
edges depend corresponding to a walk
so they're like it's these are infinite
number of books yeah
this is this right now is an infinite
interpretation in terms of random box I
will of course not use this explicitly
right but this gives me actually a very
simple way to sample them
and here is my sure complement sampling
procedure
so we'll just do random works so do the
following so uh here's the way to
achieve an unbiased approximation to the
sure complement by using what we call
terminal random box
so let me describe it visually and then
I will show it formally so here is the
blue vertices are the vertices you're
eliminating these are the F vertices
everything outside is T
pick an edge
right it it doesn't have to be entirely
inside it can be crossing that's okay
but let me show you what happens inside
now start from one of the end points
take a random work so green green Green
until you exit
do the same with your other vertex so
you do purple purple purple
and you end up
and now I will add an edge
here
between the two endpoints that you
obtained
right is the process clear to everyone
I start I take two random walks one each
from the end points of the edge okay and
keep random walking until you exit
f
and the moment you exit f u stop
I will assign them weights that are as
follows the weight of the new Edge that
you're adding
is the inwards of the sum of the
inverses of the weights
there's actually an electrical
interpretation
if each of if this entire walk right
combining the green the orange Edge and
and the purple if the entire walk
was if you view it as a sequence of
resistors because the resistance is one
over w i
then this is the total resistance of the
path
that's in so it's really falling out of
the electrical interpretation also it's
very consistent with that
uh that's right that's why there's the
file meaning sorry thank you so so
weight is the inverse of the instances
which is the sum of
you do it for all
oh for all ages for all the edges that
touch the vertex I'm eliminating I will
do these two random works until you exit
and add an edge there
right let me just write that formally so
for every Edge UV
random walk from U until it hits the
first vertex x and t
right if U was in t you just stop you
don't take
similarly walk from the other end point
until you hit
the set outside and then I will add
an edge across these two new endpoints
that I've determined
where the weight is given by as a
function of the entire walk
so let W be the entire walk that goes
from
X to u u v
back to y
right so combine the two random works
with this with the sample Edge that's
the entire walk w
and my weight is exactly 1 over
the sum of inverses of the weights on
the walk
is a process clear can I answer
questions you said you take a note in
all its neighbors
that was the interpretation for
eliminating a single vertex right now
I'm giving you a sure complement
interpretation for eliminating a block
of vertices together okay so you're
saying to every Edge every Edge that's
right
in fact you can do this for every Edge
if the edge was incident of TNT both the
random Works will be empty and you will
add the exact same Edge
right if it was crossing you will take
it just from one side and
different side you take both so you can
you literally do this for every agent
it's the same
problem another question
is there anything in particular that
motivation particular design choice for
your sampling algorithm yes but let me
take that
I think I have the time to basically
complete the proof from it so uh it's a
great question but but let me come back
but but are you are you happy with the
with the process currently like
so something that I that maybe we don't
have the time to completely true but it
immediately follows from the random of
interpretation that this process is
unbiased
if you take the expectation
in expectation you get the complete
should complement exactly
and the proof is literally the same you
are basically sampling all random works
the interesting part is how does this
weight pop out and let me just say the
following that you will add an edge X Y
to the end points it will end up
by it can start from any of the edges on
the work
and each of them will contribute a
weight 1 over W1 they will all add up to
the original weight so
forget about the weights but just if I
have an entire walk
I can I can get an edge on X Y from this
walk starting from any of the edges on
the walk
right if I have four edges on the work
each of them could have led to this
weight corresponding to the same work
right so I so I have to somehow
distribute the weights between them and
this Choice ends up Distributing them in
the right way
okay but so I will not prove it but it's
really just verifying that in
expectation this process generates the
same interpretation
of the sure complement in terms of the
random walks
while we're looking at uh this
definition and thinking about
resistances and
thinking about the other toxic happens
or anything you want to say about share
compliments and vertex parts
so this is
exactly like the idea of sure complement
is an exact vertex parsifier when you're
looking at this L2 problem solving or
the energy of the effective circuit
Right Touch of all was talking about
vertex parsifiers in most problem
settings vertex parts are approximate
but L2
just like shortest path or the min max
that he was talking about L2 turns out
to be a setting the quadratic energy
turns out to be a setting where sure
complement gives you an exact vertex
possible which preserves effective
resistances preserves the energy if you
are only focusing yourself to these
subset of vertices that you keep thanks
sir
for every two vertices in t the vertices
I'm I'm keeping I want to preserve
effective resistances let's say they are
preserved exactly with the sure content
yes
ah good so so let's come back to that
question was do we need to bound the
length let's observe some very simple
properties of this
sampling process
each random work is actually log in
steps with high probability why because
I'm working with the 5dd set from a 5D
reset I will like at every step I exit
it with constant probability so it's a
very short random number in fact when
you sum them all up you will only get
total running time of order M you don't
even lose the login because these are
concentrations of sums of geometric
random variables
[Music]
right so the total as long as m is
just like greater than log n you will
get concentration with that the total
amount of time you spent doing the
sampling is basically ordering
the total number of edges that I get in
the sure complement sample that I'm
generating is actually the total number
of edges in the original graph because I
drew one sample for every Edge that
existed
[Music]
so yes it gets a little denser if I
reduce the vertices by half it grows up
by a factor of two but it's not growing
to quadratic
right
so and in I don't expect like I don't
this expect this process to blow up
it would not be nice if this was 2m it's
really exactly the number of edges that
you started
and this thing that I said in words but
you can verify it it's really an
equality in expectation you get exactly
the shoe company
right and now is where we want to throw
we want to throw back to the previous
lecture about Matrix concentration when
do you get graph
approximation you need two properties
you need exact expectation
and two you need each Matrix sample has
a small Norm Epsilon squared by log n
right so we have the expectation
so the only piece I need to show or we
need to work through is can we ensure
that each of the samples gives you a
small
Norm right each of the samples has a
small leverage score if it has a small
average score then we are done
then you've actually built an
approximation a spectral approximation
to The Shield
okay in like three minutes maybe I'll
run over two a couple more but but it's
a very simple proof from here
so how do we achieve sure approximation
I'm just reminding us that we saw in the
first lecture we want every Matrix
sample you generate
to have leverage score that's bounded by
Epsilon squared by log n so if I add an
edge e with with weight WV I want w e
effector resistance of e to be smaller
than Epsilon Square
if this is true then I would have built
an Epsilon approximation to the sure
complement spectral approximation
key observation that makes this work is
the four line
that if I guarantee that in my original
graph right I started with an original
graph I am producing an ex an
approximation to the should complement
if I guarantee that in my original graph
every Edge has a small leverage called
Epsilon squared by log n
then in fact each sample Edge has a
small limited score
same like if you if you have a uniform
bound on all edges you get the same
bound on all the samples
why
so let's prove this it's a very simple
proof and the key is what was a sampling
weight
and this is the inspiration that you
were talking about because we want this
to be true so we will use triangle
inequality of effective resistances I
know I didn't prove it uh it's an
interesting fact about effective
resistances that effective resistances
form
a metric they give you triangle
inequality u v v w the effective
resistance between U and W is smaller
than the sum of the effective
resistances between the two pairs
I'm not saying leverage scores effective
resistances
right this is slightly surprising
because the most natural thing you get
is is actually that the square root of
the effective resistances give you
triangle inequalities that's a much
easier proof
because it's just you can just view them
as vectors in L2 space and you get the
triangle inequality but the square one
is also true and it can be proven but we
will believe we will buy that now let me
show you with the triangle inequality
that I naturally get bounded sample Norm
so suppose
let me I'll do it by approved by example
so I I started with sampling from an
edge UV
from UI took a random walk to X just one
Edge from V I took a random walk to Y I
added an edge x y
what is was the weight it's a length
three walk my weight is 1 over
sum of 1 over w i
so this is weight times the effective
resistance this is the leverage score of
the edge I'm adding
weight times effectiven this is the
leverage score of the edge I'm adding I
want to show this is small
I'm going to start with the triangle
inequality so I'm going to apply a
triangle inequality to the effective
resistance to say oh just apply it all
over the path so I get the distance from
X to u u to v v to Y this was the part
this was the walk that gave me the edge
x y
and I have 1 over w i
rewrite each of these as 1 over W1 times
W one r
1 over W 2 times W 2 r 1 over W3 times
what have I got these are leverage
scores of the original edges
that you actually sample the walk with w
i r i these are leverage scores of the
original edges which I assumed were
bounded by Epsilon squared by log n
and this is a weighted sum of the of the
leverage scores weighted convex
combination so this is bounded by
Epsilon Square
now the Matrix concentration theorem
just directly applies and you're
guaranteed that it's an Epsilon
approximation to the sure complement
right and how do I achieve this
the same trick I will split every Edge
into parallel edges
login over Epsilon squared copies
parallel edges and you scaled on the
weight so now every multi-edge has small
effective resistance and when you draw
samples you will end up with small every
multi has a smaller leverage score and
when you sample you end up with a small
level score
right so
so now we got both the things you sample
with the right expectation each sample
has a small Norm Epsilon Square by log n
so I'm guaranteed that I have achieved a
Epsilon approximation to the short
complement
okay this is just one iteration but now
you can instead of working with Epsilon
you work with Epsilon over log n
and now and then you get error Epsilon
over log n and I can add it up login
times to add it to end up with only
total Epsilon approximation all the way
right so
I already mentioned that you can achieve
smaller score by splitting the
beforehand so we recurse login times
with a smaller Epsilon to get the
complete algorithm right so at the end
of login iterations you have a
factorization with triangular matrices
block diagonal whereverly block diagonal
is easy to invert and triangular and
this allows you to write an easy inverse
which is an approximation to the
laplacian and now use
refinement with the laplacian to get
good here are the four logs there are
the four logs thank you uh so right now
what happened was I got
um
you you've
if you replace Epsilon by
Epsilon over log this gets your log Cube
and you have to make copies so you
initially started with M lock cubed
edges but at every iteration I have m m
log cubed edges so I get another log and
I'm
right I'm log okay let me say this again
so replace Epsilon by Epsilon over log n
this becomes Epsilon squared over log n
cubed so I want to make the initial
leverage score to be this small
so I break up each of the edges into
log cubed n copies
so right so now the original graph is
I'm working with has M log cubed n edges
parallel like many of them parallel but
I have log n depth of iteration where at
every time I'm working with a graph with
the same number of edges so I get
another factor of log n and that's M log
to the 4 running time
there's an implicit representation of
this word complement uh I I'm building
an approximation implicitly in the sense
that I'm not allowed to write down the
explicitude
approximation this explosive the show
the approximation is explicit you have
to write it down every in every
recursion yeah that's right I do write
down the shoulder approximation but I'm
not here yes but I'm not allowed to ride
the shoot complex yeah
yeah that's all I meant by implicit yeah
yeah I can't write it down and then
apply what the specification below
okay and really that's it let me just
conclude uh I'll let we are running over
and I don't want to keep people from
lunch so let me just quickly so it's a
very simple Applause it's all good right
I basically completed the entire two M
log to the four and running time you can
shave off a login by using Matrix uh
Matrix martingales rather than doing
Matrix
sponsor it just makes the proof Messier
but like this is much easier to present
I think uh it can be parallelized you
get basically log squared and depth like
log n depth from each and each operation
is just log n depth you can also improve
it by something called Black Box sub
sampling based on a uniform
approximation sampling paper by Iron and
quarters
and this gives us a lot of improved
parallel algorithms for spectrums
algorithms I mean just conclude the
thank you
[Applause]
thank you questions so the size of the
the size of the approximation is M
logged at the fourth end
uh you you have to do this iteration to
actually solve the system that's right
so so so is there not another fact so
Bob is asking about what is the size of
the approximation so when I write down
L the laplacian as a product of matrices
the total number of non-zeros I end up
with is M up to the foreign
over Delta outside but that's not a log
n over Delta you only if you wanted to
solve it to constant error you don't pay
another login
right but this log 1 over Delta is sort
of like that's an additional factor in
all LaPlace and software
all of them basically build an
approximation and then solve we
yeah not in linear space
a good question so so someone is asking
Philip is asking can it be done in
linear space you mean really m space
order Ram even
I don't of anything I think the best is
basically the running timeout okay
okay there is there is a partial yes
there exists factorizations that take a
lot more time to compute like that will
give you order m non-zeros
but I don't know how to achieve that
efficiently
right and this algorithm definitely
takes import
ant let me get back to you there is
interesting work on log space solvers
there's a whole other difference
for practical application I know it's
hard to get them
it's hard to get the practitioners to
use this stuff it's complicated but I
would think that they would care about
space actually that's very
basically is this practical line would
would improving the space help there is
actually a bunch of work so there was a
previous version of this kind of
elimination based solver that I had with
Erasmus that was eliminating vertices
one by one randomly
and Rasmus and Dan Spielman and one of
raspers's students they have they in
fact have a paper out and an
implementation of that solver that does
well in all scenarios it it's it doesn't
beat the specialized solvers that are
built for 2D grades right but it but it
basically never breaks and gives you a
reasonable time everywhere and they've
done a comprehensive uh comprehensive
comparison to other
s it works good but they are pushing
these into practice has already been a
two decade long and maybe one more
decade would do it
again
I wanna I'm scared to
yeah I mean even in the competency
when even when building it okay I don't
know of any such one but but yeah
the fun thing to debate after break I'm
not entirely sure I happen to discuss
that more after a break sorry I said I
should wait for lunch and I Focus I mean
more questions
we discussed over let's just translate
to a distributed algorithm like a good
question so the question is whether this
translates or distributed algorithm we
tried this one does not but there is a
different
significantly more involved distributed
algorithm and some of the causes
and yeah there is a distributed
algorithm that achieves M poly log
running time
okay but but this one does not work but
we were hoping because it is so simple
and seems local but but the problem is
when you take these random walks now
simulating these random walks in a spa
in an efficient way in the disabled
Network gets very tricky and that that
fails like all at least all all the
operations we tried and I'm sure they
had also tried it previously
or not
all right
[Music]
um and then you'll have a lunch break uh
the next talk will be at two o'clock uh
with
welcome see you all then
thank you